andres sur les marchés cette activité
philippe et xavier pupa on avait un peu
perdu l'habitude il travaille
d'ordinaire sur d'autres circuits du
fait du premier confinement et du
deuxième le passage à la cave ne se fait
plus du tout on a les restaurants qui
sont aussi fermés donc une clientèle
qu'on a pu et donc bas seul moyen c'est
de revenir sur des marchés donc des
marchés de producteurs au moins 70 % de
chiffre d'affaires depuis le début du
confinement pour les vignerons
- 20 voire -30% pour ces apiculteurs cet
automne la situation est plus compliquée
qu'au printemps comme on a ouvert une
boutique en vente directe à la ferme on
avait quand même beaucoup de gens on a
raison pas un cas des maisons
secondaires qui venait le vendredi et
samedi acheter nos produits et incite
les produits locaux qu'on a dans la
boutique pour ce deuxième confinement
bas comme les gens continuent à
travailler normalement
on a quand même une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires mais beaucoup moins de monde
le week end alors pour tenir il faut
piocher dans sa trésorerie et dans ces
cas là difficile de penser à l'avenir
sereinement
on n'a pas trop de visibilité justement
nous vous les agrandir encore l'élevage
mais voilà aujourd'hui on se pose des
questions on sait pas quoi faire on sait
pas facile quoi donc heureusement qu'il
ya encore des petits marchés comme ça
pour qu'on puisse vendre notre notre
produit quoi cet éleveur a bien fait de
venir les clients étaient nombreux
l'événement sera pérennisée et tous les
marchés régionaux
je pense que c'est super important de
s'y tenir nos petits producteurs
le troisième dimanche de chaque mois
nous continuerons ce type de marché des
producteurs pour maintenant en faire une
coutume est une habitude
rendez-vous à beaune la rolande le 20
décembre pour le second marché
la commune voisine de l'addon
rassemblera elle aussi des producteurs
le week-end prochain